yeah he went to welcome to video playing
Z's Oh master and to God I cannot so I
have turned to felonious apparel
transposing to the French exchange which
really takes some people back like him
for example yeah I'm already quite happy
really
okay he does not mind his pawn structure
to be weakened hmm okay yeah I mean this
is not winning or anything but the
double pants there will be an eternal
issue yeah
do I want to trade it's not ideal to be
honest maybe should have played aged
three because I don't have 95 anymore
which I'm did not really with which
didn't really register with me
[Music]
okay one move earlier yet Bishop b2 now
he does not have that not sure what she
six is all about
I just want to gain a bit of space and
night g2 III is an interesting way to
place the night the night is attacking
d5 and I can also go to f4 of course
attacking d5 and with g5 being a
potential ATM they just wants to trade
the house and think he will get it drawn
that way and not on my watch
you're not going to get a simple draw
here I'm not sure about it though how to
do it
therefore I want to play ultimately but
yeah you still have some time him says
to go I guess to you three mmm
so you want to go I don't know to g5 or
something
okay and now I already have f4 and f5 in
this position well I think I'll go for
that things very cool that he never even
invests a second but it must be the
easiest position ever to play
[Music]
I really don't think it is I'm scared
that you're going to stand okay
and just about covers everything
nobody f6 isto is only helping me right
okay so going to take I mean that that
cannot be if he takes I have 92 to f4
[Music]
don't understand why he's taking this
no no incoming chair form
[Music]
which is absolutely ideal checking D 5
and age five it's a case of a pre month
okay um I cannot soup spun him right
before and so it's wrong
maybe it's it's a bit more again to do
it with the king move and that's it
it's no harder for this knowledge this
game it is not going to be able to bring
the king over to give this night new
possibilities I know I could have played
96 before me that would have been even
easier yeah this is better than this
so promoted
yeah okay
so what this means is a say yeah there
are some inaccuracies yeah I mean dude
this is this is just very beautiful
white long-term and you're sitting on
those pawns and they are weak for no
particular compensation what I should
have done is I shouldn't have played my
ability to hear that was a bad decision
I should play something that allows me
to yeah probably eight three years the
simplest yeah he should simply take a
three take f3 should be happy to get rid
of this I mean I'm so better of course
but it's just that you are happy to get
rid of the bishop the bishop is the
eternal problem so when you should take
it and I was happy to avoid this but him
put in more points on light squares yeah
generally didn't do anything to to
hinder me from improving I just improved
the petition yeah very very much step by
step and now from here it gets justice
absolutely no fun to play
okay f5 was even stronger yeah yeah
that's that's definitely yeah that's
true actually cannot take what is he
playing I simply didn't want to allow
him to take just on principle
[Music]
we're not surviving this pawn structure
it just doesn't it just just just
doesn't happen just doesn't happen
six it was however very helpful that he
took on g5 I mean as you see from the
engine evaluation black is running into
it super swung anyway it's just too bad
with this pawn structure it's just nice
that I get a four and then the witness
extremely simple
just running out of moves pretty much by
force like him he has to give up one of
the pawns it happens and if you wreck
your pawn structure too much just that
something that won't work and you cannot
operate with five week pawns I have to
pawn islands and blackheads yeah I don't
know and it's like I didn't know what to
call it it looks weird
okay thanks for watching